there's all these non-profits that are
are just grifting extraordinaries I
would say the premier one is probably
the Lincoln project now you may remember
the Lincoln project this was a bunch of
sort of ex-republicans these were these
were McCain and Romney Republicans who
were so uh disgusted by Donald Trump
they became this group of never Trump
people and they got millions and
hundreds of millions of dollars to be
principled conservatives who never
accomplished anything but they were
better than that Donald J Trump guy who
was doing all of the stuff that they
purported to want to accomplish but
never actually could well the Lincoln
project which is super well funded which
said that it was a republican you know
the whole idea of it was we're here for
conservative values we want to save the
Republican party but we just don't like
Trump well now the mask is off with
these guys here is Lincoln project
senior advisor Stuart Stevens on what
the Lincoln project really actually does
want to do what is it could cause
Republicans like many of you at the
Lincoln project former Republicans to
say hey let's fix this party let's let's
fix it in the mold of uh of Liz Cheney
of of Adam kinsiger of conservatives who
would like to be conservative but have a
normal party and like democracy or it
could shift it in the direction that you
just indicated people who don't wave the
bloody shirt but still don't really uh
support the underpinnings of democracy
that we need in this country
yeah just to be clear I mean at the
Lincoln project well we're not trying to
save the Republican Party
we're trying to burn the Republican
party to the ground
that's an incredible admission
like I don't know if that was planned or
not planned or what but the whole idea
of it Lincoln project right Republican
project we are just going to remove
Trump from this equation and we're going
to keep fighting for Republican
principles limited government okay you
guys got it for him to admit no we
actually want to destroy the entire
Republican party and they get tons and
tons of money obviously from Democrat
donors it's like grift alert if you see
anything from the Lincoln project you
got to know that it is BS and nonsense
and a whole bunch more